so the next thing we're going to do is
bring up flavor cloud who is going to
pitch Holly who is the investor here and
then go from there yep so I guess we're
gonna be sharing sorry so I'm gonna be
an angel investor and I've done some
angel investing in the past so I've only
heard a little bit about what you do and
so we're just kind of gonna mock what I
would end up doing as an angel investor
so tell me about flavor cloud Holly
fabulous to meet you
and I want to tell you all about flavor
cloud what we do is we make
international purchases on any
retailer's website as easy as shopping
on Amazon so cheaper faster and
completely friction free so what
retailers would do is use our service in
their shopping cart and they can just
instantly ship to 220 plus countries
around the world so help me understand
because I've never worked at Amazon or
places that serve retailer so if I'm a
retailer like maybe I own like a Shopify
store you guys are I would I would go to
you to buy my raw materials no we do the
shipping logistics and customs and
duties calculation for retailers so that
if you're if you purchased from any
international website one of the
difficulties that you have is that the
shipping cost can be like huge right and
then the other issue that you can have
is that the customs and duties are
things that you find later on when you
actually get the product and in addition
to that you have to do additional
documentation you didn't expect that and
finally let's say you actually got the
product and now you're not happy with it
and you want to return it as a consumer
you're pretty much left to your own
devices and so what we do for retailers
is say that you know you figure out your
marketing strategy to get to
you know these all ship to all these
different countries and what we'll do is
the underlying plumbing to make that
happen it seems like you're making
shipping up so I I own an online store
and I want to ship it to somebody in
Wisconsin I would use you guys that's
right so no not Wisconsin this is the
International shipping right so this is
cross-border commerce okay so if I want
to Australia somebody in Australia had
bought my shoes that I designed and
loved yeah then so currently what would
I do now I would just force the consumer
right I think that's what I would
imagine so today is that most retailers
in the last two years have seen that
because of Amazon and because of you
know social media like Instagram and
snapchat and all of that consumers are
directly finding these brands and
they're like okay I want to go buy this
right and then the retailer says I'm not
I don't I'm not equipped to ship to you
because you're located in China or
you're located in Sweden or wherever it
is right and it used to be that it was
10% of a retailer's business was
international in just the last three
years what what has happened is that it
has become a one-in-three ecommerce
purchases are cross-border right so if
you don't do that you miss out on 40 to
60% of the international traffic that
comes to your website in the US it's
about 40% if you go to like China or EU
it's well over 60% of the traffic that's
the internet so currently like how many
dollars does that translate to that's a
trillion dollar business by 2020 serving
a billion consumers worldwide okay so
how I mean right now then I feel like
it's DHL that I get international
packages from or eventually USPS and yes
certainly I could get it in three to
five days if using DHL and then like 21
days is like the slow boat
breath like how are you guys set up to
be able to compete with those yeah great
restaurant pay like 25 bucks as the end
consumer right so great question so what
we talked about was the consumer
experience of you know how hard it is to
do international but what we do is we're
a b2b SAS platform right we have suite
of services that you can plug in there's
ap eyes and plugins for Shopify and
merchants right so what we do for these
guys is three things one we integrate
with a hundred plus carriers around the
world so that's our logistics platform
we have an algorithm that goes across
that network of carriers and says what
is the cheapest fastest most efficient
way to move this product from point A to
point B which is across country borders
right and it takes historical
performance for that route and also
specific to the product to come up with
a recommendation just right off the bat
because we have these contracts with
these carriers and it's a volume-based
play across a whole suite of retailers
you're looking at like 80 plus percent
savings on shipping so imagine if you go
as a customer today on this website and
you have a shipping cost of $60 if you
go with us you have $10 shipping and
you're like okay that increases your
conversion rate right off the bat the
second thing that we do for retailers is
we have a customs engine so let's say
you have thousands of SKUs or even
millions of SKUs right if you're an
enterprise retailer the the real
nightmare with international is that you
have to classify every single product
and come up with this weird code and
that defines what the duties are and the
paperwork is a massive pain in the ass
and so what happens is you have to as a
retailer have a logistics team that
understands the inherent details and
that's a huge cost that most retailers
don't understand how far along are you
like how are you set so we we actually
started with a vertically integrated
marketplace in 2014 what does that
that means we enabled through our
marketplace small and medium-sized
businesses sell to consumers worldwide I
started that because as an end consumer
I had problems purchasing from these
international websites so we created
that and initially it was three markets
US UK India and then we started
experimenting with this and we figured
out with 300 plus brands that we scaled
to 100 plus countries worldwide and we
found that this anywhere to anywhere
logistics infrastructure that we had
built became the one that they were most
interested in and we started getting
requests for brands that didn't want to
be in the marketplace but still wanted
to use our technology so then what we
did was we took the back in and said
we're gonna create this SAS
infrastructure and make it such that you
know you can simply plug and play so you
don't need to worry about any of these
other aspects of so much you have about
300 brands on your site using that to
our own marketplace it sits on top of
our infrastructure and last year we made
the pivot to the SAS platform that was
in the summer and then before the
holidays we started onboarding customers
to our Shopify plugin and we have a
dozen customers for the shoe quick
questions like how much is like how much
shipping volume have you done through
your platform so we did about a hundred
KGMB through our shipping platform for
the external customers 6% Commission so
basically on order value okay so that's
been our revenue outside of the
marketplace and we have a pipeline of
customers it's been really great the
feedback that we've gotten so we're
looking at 10x in the next four months
okay and sorry I lied it's actually
three questions total many competitors
yes and so it's you think you guys are
the ones that are gonna so the
competitors this is kind of a greenfield
space because cross-border Commerce has
grown in the last two years and we've
seen the trends happen
two years the biggest competition is a
company called Pitney Bowes they have a
solution called water free
it's a 2.5 billion dinosaur company but
it's also dinosaur technology it is
geared towards it's something that
customers hate and it's geared towards a
market by market kind of implementation
which is very prohibitive for the
smaller companies and your other
question was about so basically what
makes us better in this sense and why we
are best equipped is I actually spent 10
years in supply chain logistics working
with carriers UPS DHL you know all the
guys that you mentioned I built customs
integration solutions but I also built
route optimization solutions but more so
from the other side of it so I
inherently understand the problems and
then with my co-founder at Microsoft I
built enterprise solutions it's our very
last question which I usually ask is how
much are you looking to raise and at
what valuation so we've raised 1.2
million in two rounds seed rounds so far
my second round is halfway through and
I'm raising another million for the next
nine months and that value a should do
it's ten million right now valuation cap
pre I'll get back to you thank you can
you send me the deck yes oh yeah dad
very nice meeting you thank you
what's up boys okay and we're snuff how
are you I'm Holly you founder of clever
flout cloud sorry flavor cloud tell me a
little bit about flavor cloud is stripe
for international shipping so online
merchants in under five minutes can they
just plug it into their online check
flow and or checkout flow and voila
every they can do International shipping
and deal with customs and everything
I mean you handle the payments and yeah
just payments - no we don't do the
payments we we just so how it works is
the the merchant will send us through
our API the customers address and then
we automatically real-time determine the
best route and the best price to ship it
to them how like how big of a problem is
this right now so right now what one if
you want to do international shipping as
a u.s. merchant typically what you do is
you hire really expensive consultants
who spend weeks if not many months many
many months charging now really right
now trying to figure out all the
different combinations for first my last
mile customs customs is worse for all
these types of countries and even when
they finish with that it's you know
typically there's still issues packages
still get lost everything still gets
stuck in customs and so it's just one
big hassle and that's if you can even
afford it so I think the problem is any
anybody in the US any merchant who wants
to sell goods to anyone in the world
will be using us very soon that's a
pretty big market so where are you guys
so big I can't say it so how far long
are you guys so we launched in 2014 and
the reason why we started working on
this is because we launched as a
marketplace for all sorts of brands and
retailers who were selling through us
and when we realized while they were
selling goods through us which was great
and it was going well their major
problem was international shipping and
so we decided we would solve that
problem for them and then as a result we
just decided to work on that problem
itself because it was big enough so I'm
gonna ask the elephant in the room like
what about Amazon why couldn't they set
this out because you know what they have
they have shipping locations all around
the world they're just going to
Australia - well oh okay so and I mean
Amazon's a great way to distribute your
product but I think every every
merchants some a lot of merchants
actually don't work through Amazon but I
think every every every brand for sure
once still to have their own site and
actually when you for Amazon it doesn't
actually cater to all international
customers and so in fact if they use us
we have a bigger distribution than them
yeah because we cater to everybody in
the world it's good point I mean if
you're in Antarctica have you shipped so
what like what other competitors aren't
there outside of it was not like I can
see what it retailers may not want to go
over here but there's got to be somebody
else that's cracking this or what what
yeah yeah I mean so they're they're
there other that there are a few other
startups that are taking taking a crack
at it but what we do well is we
aggregate everything so most of the
stars are taking a very fragmented
approach so they can only ship to one
country or you know they're trying to
build up something that you worried that
they're going to do what you're gonna do
and like what makes you guys kind of so
I have ten years of experience in
logistics working at UPS and other
various places and so what I know very
deeply is I know the the the people
doing the delivery the company's doing
delivery I know how to talk to them
and we've developed an out many
algorithms to put this all together so
how much are you looking to raise and at
what valuation I am looking to raise a
million dollars and our valuations ten
million dollars what are you looking to
use with that money so right now our
team is very very small and so we need
to expand our engineering team and we're
looking for people to help on the
operation side okay well how about this
why don't you go ahead and send me the
deck I'll take a look at it
are there any references that you can
give me as well yeah we have customers
we work with over 300 brands already so
you can talk to them what do you what do
you think how interested are you in this
well so I'll be honest I've never
invested on a shipping logistics type of
company so I don't really have as much
of a background on it but what's very
interesting is this is like could be a
very big business when I could get a
piece of that so usually I'm looking for
something that can give me greater than
10x returns my cheque sizes usually
range from 100 K to 250 K so I'll want a
certain percentage of the company as a
result of that and I want to be able to
keep pro-rata rights as I go further
okay so definitely up for discussion or
around his half-filled and so we expect
to close in about two weeks so I'll show
you the deck and hopefully we can chat
further very very soon thank you very
much
[Applause]
I'm taking that check yeah I think I
think my biggest one feel AK is probably
just shortening the explanations of what
you do I can see you have a huge huge
vision for this which is great but I
think just being a little bit more
succinctly your one-liner I forgot what
it was you said stripe for logistics and
I'm lucky enough to know what stripe is
but you know even if it didn't have to
like sometimes a 4 B doesn't totally
work I should have asked you I said I
said stripe for international shipping
and I assumed you're a tech investor so
it did take me it did take me that's one
of the things I have a problem and in
the sense that I've said depending on
you know whether they know it I said
flex support for b2c e-commerce but that
only works with some folks and I hate to
say Ober for like you know international
shipping you could just say you were an
API I mean stuff with the stripe analogy
there is any easy like five minute six
five minutes to putting a checkout flow
easy and you're doing a ton of work in
the back but no one else sees it yeah
yeah I also I was a little tripped up on
like I kind of knew you're selling to
retailers but like for me I just
personally couldn't like figure out the
what at what it was that's why I spent a
ton of time just like okay what it what
is this thing and that's mainly we're
just more than the bulk of it and then
once I could figure out that they
obviously had a ton of questions
afterwards - yeah and this is a reminder
for everyone actually you you you ask
the question which I was hoping you
wouldn't ask the question but a lot of
people actually go to meetings with to
investors and don't ask for money like
you just end with it without asking and
even if it's awkward just ask it
with confidence and I mean the worst
they'll say no is but you'll take all
these meetings anyway and a lot of
people will say no so don't worry about
that Bart and I will say this a lot of
times what happens and I didn't probably
mock it to you well it is usually the
first question I asked for is like how
can I help is usually what I asked that
person and then so it's true the
entrepreneur has to guide it to I'm
asking for money this is what I'm
looking for and I think what door did
what on the founder side definitely ask
what the investor is interested in this
might not even be their domain you might
not even want them it could be like a
bad investor what is their check size
what are their expectations how fast can
they move do they need to talk to
somebody else but overall you do really
well she's raising money is are they any
investors in this audience yeah that
sounds really cool
there we go two to three over there okay
all right cool
all right thank you so much thank you
thank you so much
you